you took me up the opticians the other
day and I thought because I'm desperate
to you know get back into standards I'm
sort of sitting there you know and the
guys go we're gonna do over oil toast my
wife's sitting with you gonna hear you
can't see anything
so I'm sitting there and I'm trying make
jokes you said I'll read the wall chart
I'm not Oh clapping while in Mecca lower
cover in the way then he goes read the
water and then he switches all the
lights out now I can see school clothes
he's like he's like examining me right
here it's right here he's like what can
you see my nose over here can you see
what really freaks her out if you just
if when they're in really close to go
what can you say mango
[Applause]
it brings this huge apparatus over you
know they bring that big thing they put
it on your face I said I'm not wearing
these
and put some slide fittings in it we can
see it's holidays in California you know
she does all these photos it's doing me
edging and of course you know doing the
play working with actors and stuff like
that it's really interesting
[Music]